So now that we have seen what ILP is, and
also how it relates to IPC, we can have a little discussion about the ILP and
the IPC. We have defined our ILP as basically the IPC on an ideal [UNKNOWN] for
the processor that has perfect branch branch fiction, enough resources for
everything, et cetera. And we've saw that, ILP is larger than or
equal to the IPC that can be achieved on any real processor. So
if we consider a narrow issue in-order processor, narrow issue meaning that it
can only issue about maybe one, two, maybe three instructions per cycle and
it's in-order. Usually, the limitation for the IPC will be this.
Basically the in-order property now is going to hurt us too much. So
this processor is going to be limited mostly by the narrow issue. However,
if we have a wide issue in-order processor, meaning it can do more instructions
per cycle. It's going to be limited mostly by, the in-order property.
Because this is going to allow you to do a lot of instructions per cycle, and
if it can do closely to what the ILP already is for the application,
then basically we're already kind of close to ideal as far as the IPC is
concerned for, for the wide issue problem. But because of the in-order property,
we just cannot find those instructions to keep our wide issue slots busy.
So if we have a wide issue processor, we also need for it to be out of order, so
that it can benefit from the wider issue by finding instructions anywhere where
they are and not basically stopping on the first dependence. So such a processor
will need to, fetch execute et cetera, more than one instruction per cycle,
preferably a lot more than 1. So it cannot be just like 2,
it should be 4 maybe or more, that's why we call it wide issue.
It should be able to eliminate false dependencies betw, because if we
have to obey all sorts of dependencies then that's going to limit our IPC too.
And bring us far away from the ideal ILP. And finally, should be able to
reorder instructions so that we can execute the instructions out of order.
Meaning that, our execution order should be kind of similar to what we did for
the ILP, and not for what we did for the in order processors.